o
quem já conhecia aqui quem aprendeu
muito hoje
quem está feliz eu estou muito feliz de
estar aqui
primeiro porque eu adoro pessoas
conhecer pessoas não vêm aqui tem pois
as caras lindas de vocês aí uma vista
maravilhosa
depois porque eu adoro aprender eu
aprendi muito hoje com todos vocês
palestrantes e terceiro porque eu adoro
cumprir bush eu adoro ajudar as pessoas
a conseguirem mais na vida e eu vou
fazer agora com vocês o meu nome alex eu
sou francês nos últimos quatro anos eu
morei principalmente londres mas no
méxico na uganda também e eu cheguei há
cinco meses aqui em brasília e eu vim
pra cá pra mim a multinacional para
abrir um negócio aqui a pergunta que
mais me traz reflexão da vida é que faz
a diferença na qualidade da vida das
pessoas porque algumas pessoas como a
gente viu aqui começam a vida com
condições horríveis sofrem coisas
injustas e muitas vezes não sempre mas
muitas vezes são as pessoas que mais
contribui ao bem estar da humanidade e
por outro lado outras opções que tem
tudo para ser feliz
acabam depressivos e entrando e saindo
de reabilitação que faz a diferença na
qualidade de vida das pessoas na
felicidade na arte porque não é uma
ciência é uma arte da felicidade
então hoje eu quero falar um pouquinho
de duas coisas os dois pilares da
felicidade uma parte que é o futuro tem
uma visão inspiradora tem uma meta tem
um objetivo na vida uma coisa que você
quer lugar no futuro que é um pilar
essencial e que tem a ver com em que
você se foca quais são as perguntas que
vocês se faz e dois metros e por outro
lado é o momento presente é poder sentir
a felicidade agora viver as emoções
positivas no presente e vai trazer
algumas reflexões sobre questões que
temos pra você
quando cheguei em brasília eu tive que
conseguiam cnpj tentar conseguir um
visual pra mim o norueguês que trabalha
aqui um monte de problemas
administrativos
vocês acreditam que é a coisa que eu
mais ouvi o sistema está fora do ar
não posso fazer nada e eu estou contando
isso em qualquer momento tem três
perguntas que fazem a diferença na
felicidade das pessoas
a primeira pergunta é em que eu vou me
focar agora eu posso me focar que eu tô
sendo o último palestrante do dia e que
algumas pessoas já saíram então eu vou
poder ter menos impacto ou não posso me
focar em que estou encerrando o texas
universidade de brasília e votar um
último toque de inspiração que vocês são
as pessoas mais motivados que ficaram
até o final já muda meu estado né
quando eu estava sentando na
administração brasileira para fazer
todos esses processos e que as pessoas
falavam que o sistema está fora do ar
que significado eu dou pra isso o
significado que eu comecei nos primeiros
meses era eles não querem me ajudar
eles não valorizam o meu negócio aqui
ele não quer que venha contribuir o
futuro desse país tão importante tão
maravilhoso nessa cidade central que o
cérebro desse país
ou eu mudei meu choque eu disse não isso
quer dizer que se o brasil o país 58
mais eficiente do mundo na lista muito
baixo é porque tem uma oportunidade de
crescimento
o brasileiro organiza um carnaval eles
fazem coisas perfeitas maravilhosas será
que se eu conseguir captar esse
potencial e trazer essa energia o brasil
não vai contribuir ao melhoramento
incrível de toda a humanidade mudou um
pouco minha energia ea sensação dessas
instituições nesses processos de espera
ea terceira pergunta é que você vai
fazer
a ação que vai ser que você vai tomar
que estão definidas pelo que vocês
enfoca tem um bilhão de informação
chegar no meu cérebro agora eu me foco
na positiva eu dou um significado
empregador e eu faço uma coisa
construtiva para a humanidade né
então preste a primeira parte vamos
falar do sonho de vocês que é mais
importante pra vocês na vida que vocês
querem da vida eu vou falar pra vocês
que todos nós temos uma pergunta
primordial uma pergunta que a gente faz
todo dia e que a pergunta mais
importante na nossa vida que quem essa
pergunta pra vocês que essa pergunta que
kia vida de vocês
eu trabalhei com pessoas de todos os
lados com a mulher executiva e diretora
de empresa eu trabalhei com pessoas
depressivas que iriam se suicidar
adivinha qual era a pergunta primordial
na vida delas porque todo mundo me odeia
imagine como uma pergunta dessa o teu
cérebro encontra uma resposta para
qualquer pergunta que se faz
eu descobri que nos últimos dez anos da
minha vida
a pergunta primordial que me fazia é
como eu posso conectar para ser aceitado
para ser integrado como estrangeiro
sempre de fora sempre diferente
essa pergunta foi incrível por um lado
ela me trouxe a capacidade de criar um
retorno e uma rede de 3 mil
colaboradores em países diferentes já
por 35 países conectar no mundo
por outro lado se imaginam como eu me
sinto com a pressuposição de que eu
preciso conectar para poder ser aceitado
eu tô sempre criando conectar eu não
posso ficar tranqüilo respirar sentir a
felicidade do momento
nessas sentem essa dificuldade de ter
sempre nessa ação sem poder relaxar e aí
eu decidi mudar essa pergunta eu escolhi
com a pergunta deve ser pra eu vir a
pessoa que eu quero virar no final da
minha vida que eu escolhi essa pergunta
e assim como que eu posso dar ainda mais
do amor de deus que o receba cada
instante para contribuir ao bem estar de
toda a humanidade desde que essa é a
pergunta que eu ia me condicionar para
fazer ela conscientemente
inconscientemente o tempo todo
uma pergunta que tem um pressuposto que
o jato recebendo esse amor que eu já
estou dando mais que eu posso dar ainda
mais sentem a diferença de empoderamento
que essa pergunta me trouxe ea
capacidade de poder relaxar de poder
viver o momento presente né
então eu vou falar pra vocês 6
necessidades humanas que todos nós temos
eu quero saber códigos todos nós estamos
focados nessas seis mas eu quero que
cada um de vocês me diga qual da estrela
está sendo a prioridade na vida de vocês
agora beleza
a primeira necessidade humana é certeza
todos nós precisamos ter um grau de
certeza certeza que a gente vai ter
comida hoje certeza que o teto não vai
cair e eu vou poder falar aqui tranquilo
com vocês né
então é uma coisa que todos nós buscamos
a gente tem muita certeza que acontece a
gente sabe o que vai acontecer quando
vai acontecer e como vai acontecer
fica chato né então a gente busca
variedade diversidade que a segunda
necessidade humana
quantos de vocês já viram o filme já
tinha visto não é porque vocês viram de
novo porque tinha certeza que era bom
mas esperava ter esquecido um pouquinho
pra ter um pouco mais de variedade né
a terceira necessidade humano é
significância é se sentir o único se
sente importante sentir valorizado todos
nós queremos ter um certo status né
acorda necessidade é conexão e amor
todos nós sobrevivemos por causa do amor
o ser humano é único animal que
precisaria de dois anos de gestação para
poder ter uma função básica do corpo
dele o nascimento em 9 meses e não vai
dar mole morre
então todos nós buscamos essa coisa de
amor e conexão também essas quatro são
as necessidades da personalidade às
necessidades básicas que todos vocês vão
encontrar uma maneira de respondendo de
conseguir a sentir a sua plenitude com
elas
agora quem não consegue qual é a maneira
mais rápida de sentir todas as
necessidades e as quatro primeiras
necessidades básicas
eu posso um revólver na cabeça dele com
esta certeza que eu tenho que vai
responder entre idéias de teste com a
diversidade de que pode vir a acontecer
aqui 10 com a significância que eu tenho
na vida dele talvez ele não me conhecia
0 agora 10 nada mais importa no seu
conexão até o cinto uma conexão por
quesito aqui mas thauan até então a
violência sempre existiu e sempre
existirá enquanto a gente tiver maneiras
dizem poderá dores de encontrar de
sentir a plenitude nessas necessidades
né tem maneiras positivas negativas e
neutras e tem duas necessidades mas que
são as necessidades do espírito que a
necessidade de crescer ea necessidade de
contribuir que todos nós temos você não
pode crescer sem contribuição pode
contribuir sem crescer então todos nós
temos essas seis necessidades
levanta a mão quem aqui está se focando
na certeza como a primeira necessidade
mais importante da vida dele agora
certeza
levanta a mão ninguém é o público ted né
variedade que está buscando qualidade
11 20 e 30 40 talvez
quem está buscando significância
importância único especial valorizado
uma grande parte da audiência quem está
buscando conexão e amor
quem está buscando crescimento
principalmente quem está buscando
contribuição principalmente seja a
diversidade né
na minha vida eu passei dez anos da
minha vida ou talvez mais buscando
significância tentando ser mais
importante mas no fundo o que eu queria
ser amado ea sociedade pelo marketing me
fazer acreditar que quanto mais o
importante mas é chamado a maior mentira
que me contaram na humanidade do
marketing e da televisão
cada vez que ouvia mais importante ouvir
presidente da maior onda estudante do
mundo eu viajei encontro com o ministro
com o presidente do país
adivinha o que cada vez menos eu era
amado cada vez menos é conectado cada
vez mais sozinho estava foi a maior
mentira que me contado porque tem uma
oposição se eu chego aqui me apresento
como super importante
vocês vão querer conectar comigo ou se
apresenta como um humilde que se
esgotará ir pra mim porque todos os rios
do mundo joga no oceano porque você
nunca mais baixo que todos os rios é uma
idade que atrai
se você está buscando amor de conexão e
que estão se focando a significância não
vai dar certo vocês vão sofrer
acreditem minha experiência a segunda
coisa que eu quero transmitir a vocês é
o estado emocional tem mais de 5 mil
emoções da língua inglesa para adquirir
como a gente se sente em cada segundo
a maioria das pessoas do mundo se falar
pra vocês dez minutos para escrever
todas as emoções que sentiu nas últimas
semanas
vocês vão conseguir 12 no máximo a
metade delas vão ser negativas
imagina o que isso significa que a gente
faz com nós mesmo que nossa cérebro
constrói de nós para fazer a gente sente
isso né cadê o nível de energia de
gasolina que vai permitir a gente
alcançar esses são essas metas de ajudar
o mundo diz ter melhor cada dia a gente
precisa essa gasolina essa energia no
presente agora que a coisa que mais
determina isso é no cérebro humano
todos nós temos crenças temos coisas que
a gente vê acontece uma vez a gente
acredita
isso é alguma coisa confirma isso
confirma de novo confirma
e aí a realidade nossa criança a gente
não vê mais a diferença a gente já
confunde os dois mas a gente precisa às
vezes e desmontar os pilares que
justificam isso para criar uma nova
importante verdade sobre quem a gente é
sobre o mundo sobre a natureza do ser
humano e uma coisa que acontece é que
todos nós temos um software aqui atrás
da cabeça que estão definidos pelas
coisas que mais tão prazer na gente
quais são as emoções valores que mais dá
um prazer pra você na vida
isso são coisas que vocês vão fazer
qualquer coisa para conseguir sentir e
por outro lado pois são as coisas que
mais causam dor pra vocês na vida
vocês vão fazer tudo para evitar isso né
então uma coisa que eu faço como os
clientes é ajudar eles a entender esse
mapa de que existam mais buscando mais
evitando da vida e quais são as regras
que fazem sentir essa emoção positiva ou
negativa e trazer esse mapa do
inconsciente por consciente para vocês
poderem ver como que estão virando a
vida de vocês
para dar um exemplo quando eu fiz esse
mapa meu eu descobri que a coisa que
mais me dá prazer na vida a emoção
número 1 quer maior fonte de alegria era
me sentir o pt de ser integrado e pra eu
senti isso eu tinha uma regra
completamente louca que eu encontrei que
era que eu precisava de 100 pessoas
aplaudiam de pé chorando pra eu sentir
que eu tava parte e eu precisava que
cada 30 segundos me deram atenção vocês
acham que eu sentia integrado permanecer
muito que me sentia excluído
constantemente na minha vida e por outro
lado para me sentir rejeitado só
precisava alguém dizer não pra mim
qual é a novidade eu me sentia rejeitado
todo dia da minha vida
como vocês acham que isso vai me
permitir ter essa gasolina essa energia
de vida pra contribuir à melhora da
humanidade não vai alcançar
eu posso ter uma super meta após ter um
mapa para chegar lá mas se não tiver
gasolina não vou avançar é preciso ter a
emoção agora de como teoria quando
chegar lá quando eu consegui mudar esses
milhões de vidas empatar a pessoa
precisa sentir isso agora
então o que eu fiz eu recuperei meu mapa
mental como eu queria que fosse eu
pensei no alex de 80 anos no final da
minha vida como esposa maria e nossa
família
nossas crianças como eu quero ser para
poder ser essa pessoa e eu escolhi
conscientemente as coisas que vão me dar
prazer na vida e as coisas que vão fugir
às regras adequadas né regras como eu
vou sentir amor conexão cada vez que
olhar no olho de uma pessoa eu vou
sentir vitalidade e energia
cada vez que eu respirar eu não vou ter
que na academia dez vezes para sentir
isso eu vou sentir isso agora e agora eu
sirvo na academia dez vezes pra melhorar
e se depois eu já sinto a emoção antes
de fazer isso é um dos segredos da
psicologia positiva pra você poder fazer
mais e ter essa vontade net influenciar
de ajudar os outros né isso com um
programação neurolinguística e várias
técnicas que ajudam com coaching tudo
isso e fazer mas essa mensagem para
vocês é se vocês conseguirem definir
onde que vocês querem
e sobretudo porque eu falei com alguns
de vocês hoje nos corredores porque
vocês querem isso três vezes porque vai
no profundo e aí sai essa energia essa
inspiração que a gente escutou tanto
aqui não precisa ter um plano de ação e
não faça uma lista do que eu tenho que
fazer
tá claro a visão já vi o brasil melhor
já viu o brasília como vai ser daqui a
40 anos quando a gente contribuir eu tô
vivendo isso na minha cabeça eu já tô lá
e agora só precisa trazer pessoas que
para avançar lá não tem que fazer
esforço eu tô atraído isso não preciso
me importo do dia de manhã para ir lá e
por outro lado eu preciso sentir no
presente essa felicidade este amor essa
conexão com todos para poder curtir né
essas são as duas mensagens que eu quero
deixar com vocês e de verdade eu desejo
para vocês uma vida incrível uma vida
com uma uma linguagem para exprimir essa
emoção essa felicidade extrema esse
calor essa morosidade da metade em
português muito bom gosto dessas
palavras entendem essa emoção eu me
pergunto o que poderia ser a vida de
vocês se vocês tivessem ferramenta tão
caro essa visão tão clara e mais essa
emoção agora que vocês poderiam fazer na
vida de vocês
essa é a pergunta que eu quero deixar
vocês encerrar a vocês brigaram